[Musique]
rémy camus poursuit sa journée en face
bike avec antonio il découvre le village
médiéval de luynes avec ses petites
ruelles et tsahal classé à l'inventaire
des monuments historiques
[Musique]
areva
honnêtement je suis assez surpris de
voir le rendu avec avec le vélo parce
que sur route
ça bouge pas et sur l'herbe ça bouge pas
non plus tape-à-l'oeil a aucune
différence
après une très bonne stabilité
antonio connaît parfaitement le coin et
mène rémy vers un édifice gallo romains
et il se transformerait presse en guide
du patrimoine
une perle effectivement c'est daté du
deuxième siècle à peu près donc il
servait à alimenter l'ancienne ville de
l'hymne en oeuvre un verset way 300
mètres encore visibles en aérien
et puis au total il faisait 1 km 5 à peu
près d'accord prenait sa source dans une
rivière leur un joli donc moins bas et
du coup il est classé monument
historique c'est le plus bel ouvrage de
ce type dans tout l'ouest de la france
sympa ça valait le coup d'oeil
complètement un petit et là en plus
quand tu viens du chemin tel décalage
accru le lac duke et des as tu vois le
château d'eau et tu vois complètement la
d'aisé palais les deux époques entre ce
qui est ce qu avait été construit et
puis ce qu'on a maintenant à l'heure
actuelle intéressant en tout cas on s'en
affranchir allez on est reparti continue
la boucle
[Musique]
est intéressant avec le fath bike c'est
que ce feu est accessible à vraiment
n'importe qui tout le monde peut prendre
beaucoup de plaisir à faire du fan d'ac
après une première partie plutôt
tranquille le parcours se complique
voilà
le joli passage tu passage à gué ça
marche ouais voilà donc tu auras peut
prendre les 20 30 cm de flat
allez go
yu la prochaine fois excellent tu ne
viendras de mettre des chaussures ou un
père prof
1 je te remercie c'est ce qui manquait
cette journée tu vois au soleil un peu
d'eau et l'on va retrouver deux locaux
de collègues qui doivent aussi être en
train de s'amuser sur un petit circuit
allez c'est parti d'accord peut allez
c'est parti